[Music]  six months ago or your children this is  who we are now  this place looks like home but it's not  there's nothing out there guys we're all  alone oh I'm alive and now he's alive we  just want to be with you help there's  home everything that kept us safe  is gone there's no civilization here not  until we start one and we all fall  Ellucian good we're splitting these  ideas in their heads now they made her a  queen careful it's pity don't like the  way things are what is it exactly today  what do you have in mind instead of its  I'm not gonna ask for power we're gonna  take it not afraid of you  you should be we're so [ __ ] in over  answer chaos take havin too much power  what do they say when we can't hear  cannibal clothes killing the son they're  your friend that's what I'm afraid of  what do you want for me why don't you  run for me what I want  [Music]  you